[Music]
one of the most central themes of philip
k dick's novel the androids dream of
electric sheep one that we also don't
see really reflected that much in the
film adaptation the blade runner at
least with the same amount of importance
is that of empathy
and
empathy can be felt
towards a number of different beings
humans fellow humans right it can be
felt towards animals as we see
very importantly and it could also be
felt towards androids that is a question
that comes up in a very important way
later in the novel when deckard himself
begins feeling
empathetic towards at least certain
androids which presents a major problem
since he is a bounty hunter who is
supposed to be killing androids or
retiring them taking them out of the
life process you could say
and
empathy
is one of the dividing lines
between human beings and androids in
that androids are not supposed to be
able to
grasp or have the capacity
for empathy it's a little bit
trickier as we're going to see but so
empathy is considered to be
distinctively human and it is exhibited
clearly by most human beings who are not
institutionalized
towards animals and towards their fellow
human beings although we have to be kind
of careful with this you know think
about the very beginning of the novel
where uh
where you know deckard and and his wife
are going to have an argument and he's
about to dial up his mood and she says
you add more venom i'll add more venom
these are not particularly empathetic
responses towards each other but we do
see that they exhibit empathy towards
each other later on in the novel and you
know some other human beings do as well
they display
other emotions too and
in a very interesting
um
sort of interior monologue that dick
leads us through rick deckard speculates
about the nature of empathy this
empathetic
gift so
he tells us the empathetic gift blurs
the boundaries between hunter and victim
between the successful and the defeated
and he says two really interesting
things that give us an idea about what
empathy looks like
he says oddly it resembled a sort of
biological insurance but double-edged as
long as some creature experienced joy
then the condition for all other
creatures included a fragment of joy
however if any living being suffered
then for all the rest the shadow could
not be entirely cast off and so for
social animals or as he's calling it
here hurt animals such as human beings
we share in each other's joys and pains
in
happiness and misery and we feel towards
each other perhaps not you know exactly
what the other person
feels but it affects us and you might
think you know just to go off on a
little tangent here uh if you know your
moral philosophy you might think about
aristotle and his discussion of
friendship and nick mccain ethics book
nine where he says that friends share
joys and sorrows with each other griefs
literally
or you might think of jeremy bentham and
his discussion
of
sympathy
and
you know how that works out of
benevolence in terms of feeling
something good about somebody else
feeling good feeling bad about somebody
else feeling something bad in any case
deckard suggests that empathy makes
sense for
human beings right he says empathy
evidently existed only within the human
community
whereas intelligence to some degree
could be found throughout every phylum
and order including the arachnida
spiders and things like that
why the empathetic faculty probably
required an unimpaired group instinct a
solitary organism such as a spider would
have no use for it in fact it would tend
to abort a spider's ability to survive
it would make him conscious of the
desire to live on the part of his prey
so predators would not have
empathy including highly developed
mammals such as cats
and you know so where do where do
androids fit in with this he says
evidently the humanoid robot constituted
a solitary predator and we see in the
next line
rick liked to think of them that way it
made his job palatable in retiring that
is killing an andy he did not violate
the rule of life laid down by mercer you
shall kill only
the killers so this is in some ways
providing us with a not you know the
definitive position on empathy but
something that's nice for deckard to
think so that he can
make it through the day
now
androids in the story clearly lack
empathy for animals they don't relate to
animals in the way that human beings do
and remember that we're talking about a
future in which animals have become rare
and valued
and in which mercerism has
helped human beings to become much more
empathetic
and so this is something that's that's
really distinctive that's why the voigt
camp test
tests uh reactions to
you know
things that are happening to animals or
androids also seem to lack empathy for
humans they can relate to humans they
can be interested in them they can form
connections with them but
they don't have the empathetic response
and it's interesting because they also
lack that in relation to other
androids they can have friendships as
you know the babies and pris and um you
know the other members of that crew seem
to have they can have a kind of
uh
you know group identification but
they're ultimately
on their own and
we get to see that it's not
so simple as just one stance there's
several different possibilities so in
chapter 11 we see
inspector garland who is himself an
android this is at the fake police
station
[Music]
and he's talking about what
um
phil resch the
bounty hunter who's working at this this
fake police station
at the hall of justice um how he's going
to react because at that point in the
novel we're not sure whether phil resh
himself is an android or whether just
garland is and some of the other cops in
the place we're not even sure actually
there's been some hinting that maybe
deckard himself could be an android
although that's that's dismissed fairly
quickly
and so
inspector garland says
you know it's too bad that you know we
couldn't just sort of like leave things
alone uh he says your position would be
better if phil rush could pass this test
if it was just me the results that way
would be predictable to russia it'd be
just another andy to retire as soon as
possible so you're not in a good
position
you know and
then he explains things and he says here
comes the eager beaver phil resh back
with his handy-dandy portable little
test isn't he clever he's gonna destroy
his own life and mine and possibly yours
now this is
cognitively understood but it's not as
if garland cares
about that right
and rick says you androids don't exactly
cover for each other in times of stress
and garland says back to him i think
you're right it would seem that we lack
a specific talent you humans possess i
believe it is called empathy and so
there's a recognition that they they
don't have that
later on in isidore's apartment roy
beatty
says something quite interesting
the question is well um should isadore
turn them in or are they in danger of
that and irma guard beatty says um
i don't think we have to worry about mr
isidore
they don't treat him very well
either as he said and what we did on
mars he isn't interested in he knows us
and he likes us and an emotional
acceptance like that it's everything to
him it's hard for us to grasp but it's
true so this emotional acceptance of
priss
and the two babies right
and she says uh
to isadora you could get a lot of money
by turning us in do you realize that and
then she says to roy
see he realizes that but he still
wouldn't say anything
and roy says if he was an android he'd
turn us in about 10 tomorrow morning
he'd take off for his job and that would
be it i'm overwhelmed with imagination
and we have we are admiration and we
imagine this would be a friendless world
a planet of hostile faces all turned
against us
and um
you know there's a recognition here that
isidore at least is behaving in a
empathetic manner towards them even
though they don't
have that
when we get to rachel rosen in chapter
16
things are a bit more complicated
and she turns out to be kind of a
linchpin in in the the narrative that's
going on
so she is talking about
and chris is is made on the same
model you could say
as rachel
and that's what's going to make it
difficult for deckard to retire chris
because he's
attracted to and even
empathetically connected with rachel
so
she goes on and
she says do you know what i have towards
this priss android and deckard says
empathy and she doesn't say yes she says
something like that identification there
goes i
my god maybe that's what will happen in
the confusion you'll retire me not her
she can go back to seattle and live my
life i never felt this way before
we are machines
stamped out like bottle caps it's an
illusion that i i personally really
exist i'm just representative of a type
and he points out well ants don't feel
like that and they're physically
identical and she says ants don't feel
period and then he says well identi
identical human twins they don't and she
says but they identify with each other
i understand that they have an
empathetic special bond
and so
a little bit later she says
if i die maybe i'll be born again when
the rosen association stamps out its
next unit of my
subtype
so
this is quite interesting
she
um has some sort of connection towards
pris but it's not exactly empathy as a
matter of fact it might be might even be
viewed as
hatred or
antipathy a view that
the other is a rival to her that the
other would
take over
her
pretty
kush posh
life and no longer be an android on the
run
there's a question as well
whether androids feel any
loyalty
towards each other
in any significant way
um and that's you know that's kind of an
open
issue
right
so
loyalty
can she feel it towards him
or not
we don't really know
so we've got the possibility of
non-empathy or even antipathy towards
fellow androids
now what about humans towards androids
so we have these two bounty hunters and
it turns out that that phil resh is in
fact human he's just been working at
this fake hall of justice and it's kind
of unclear how exactly that happened
dick doesn't tell us but rick deckard
and and phil resh they have rival
tests for telling the androids apart
they
both have been hunting androids
and successfully retiring them it's
going to turn out that they have another
connection in common as well
and they go off to kill the opera singer
android uh little luft
and
it ends up being you know uh resh who
who does it
and
they take these these uh you know tests
and figure out who's who
and then deckard um
has an interesting
idea he's kind of concerned with
what is actually
going on
turns out that he has developed
empathy
and so here's the passage it's in
chapter 12.
so he says uh
this is phil rush do you have your
ideology framed that would explain me as
a part of the human race and rick says
there is a defect in your empathetic
role taking ability
one which we don't test for
your feelings towards androids
so
resh has you know the right kind of
empathy towards animals he's actually
got a pet squirrel
uh he's pretty empathetic towards humans
although deckard says you know i think
you just like killing and you'd be happy
to find out that i'm an android so you'd
have an excuse to kill me
so he's not all that empathetic towards
towards human beings but he definitely
doesn't have empathy towards androids he
has the opposite
and uh
resh says well we don't test for that
and deckard says maybe we should he
never thought of it before had he never
felt any empathy on his own part towards
the androids he killed
always he'd assumed that throughout his
psyche experienced the android as a
clever machine as in his conscious view
and yet
in contrast to phil rash a difference
had manifested itself
and he felt instinctively that he was
right
empathy towards an artificial construct
he asked himself
something that only pretends to be alive
but luba luft had seemed genuinely alive
it had not worn the aspect of a
simulation and then resh goes on and
says listen buddy this would be a
terrible thing
you realize what this would do if we
included androids in our range of
empathetic identification as we do
animals
we couldn't protect ourselves these
nexus six types they'd roll all over us
and mash us flat
you and i all the bounty hunters we
stand between the nexus 6 and mankind
a barrier that keeps the two
distinct
and then rick says yeah okay you know i
get that
i want to ask myself a question
with avoid camp test and so he does that
and he has
um resh you know observe it so that that
he can process it
and
he
here it is i'm going down by elevator
with an android i've captured and
suddenly someone kills it without
warning no particular response phil rush
said what did the needles hit and then
rick says a female android and then the
needles go
wild
and then rick says that's an
emphatically empathetic response about
what a human subject shows for most
questions except for the extreme ones
the truly pathological ones and and resh
says well what does that mean and decart
says i'm capable of feeling empathy for
at least specific certain androids not
all of them but one or two for libel
luft as an example he said to himself
and then he says so i was wrong there's
nothing unnatural or unhuman about phil
resh's reactions it's
me
and he says
i wonder if any human has ever felt this
way about an android
and resh says you know you're in a spot
deckard and
deckard says well what should i do and
rush says it's sex
sex
because she it was physically attractive
hasn't that ever happened to you before
we were taught it constitutes a prime
problem in bounty hunter and they talk
about android mistresses and so you know
maybe this can be just localized but
we find later on in chapter 15
when rick is talking to his wife erin
he says i want to talk about what
happened to me today
i met another bounty hunter one i never
saw before a predatory one who seemed to
like to destroy them
for the first time after being with him
i looked at them differently i mean in
my own way i had been viewing them as he
did
and he says i took a test one question
and verified it i've begun to empathize
with androids and look at what that
means you said it this morning yourself
those poor andes so you know what i'm
talking about so not only
does deck art
feel something towards or about
these androids his wife does too which
means that probably a lot of people do
in some way but this is going to get
right in the way of being a bounty
hunter
rash on the other hand
enjoys
the killing right he feels antipathy
towards the androids
or at least he feels perhaps nothing
towards them
now
what brings the two of them together
as we find out in the
sort of vignette the scenes with rachel
rosen
she has actually been
playing
deckard there's a whole back story there
and um
she has you know at first says well you
know i'll help you with the androids
i'll kill priss for you you know they
have sex and
then this thing where he says if you
weren't an android i could legally marry
you i would
and they talk about that and then rachel
says you look so sad
putting his hand out he touched her
cheek and then she says
you're not going to be able to hunt
androids any longer
so don't look sad please
then she goes on explaining what what
the case actually is
no bounty hunter
has ever gone on after being with me
except one a very cynical man
phil resh and he's nutty he works out in
left field on his own
i see rick said he felt numb completely
throughout his entire body and then she
she talks about you know knowing the
babies and knowing all of these other
androids and
she goes on and says um
you know we've been uh
catching up with with bounty hunters the
association wanted to reach the bounty
hunters here and in the soviet union
this seemed to work for reasons which we
do not fully understand our limitation
again so she's able to use
sex and attraction to spark empathy in
these bounty hunters that will go beyond
merely her
and get these bounty hunters to feel
empathy towards androids more generally
so that they can't keep doing
their job
killing androids
and so she says
or he says i doubt if it works as often
or as well as you say and she says but
it has with you and he says we'll see
and she says i already know
when i saw that expression on your face
that grief i look for that and he asks
how many times have you done this i
don't remember seven eight no i believe
it's nine yes nine times
and so
you know
this is a
uh
very interesting scene i mean does she
actually remember this this process that
she's gone through
have her memories been erased and
replaced um you know how does she know
that
deckard isn't going to be able to go
through with killing more
androids after
after her or rather after he's done with
this massive job
it's
through
looking at his face
something like what we would call
emotional intelligence being able to
tell what the emotions of other people
are
and yet if she doesn't have an
empathetic connection could she be right
about this there's a lot of interesting
questions that are being
raised here and so we've got you know
the possibility of empathy towards
androids androids don't themselves feel
it towards each other but human beings
can be brought to feel that we've also
got the possibility of
shifting over to the other side and
perhaps phil resch felt that he was
tricked and you know she mentions him as
cynical so maybe he uh viewed this as
manipulative which it certainly is and
then heads over to the side of antipathy
towards them as well so there's a wide
range of
possible
human reactions to androids and only one
or at least one set
of reactions that don't include empathy
between androids themselves
you